how are you guys doing
good how are you oh good how are you i'm
doing good i'm admiring the animal in
the back i'm assuming that's a
hat yeah sitting like a chicken
for both of you guys um at what point
when they called you to be in this movie
did you think it was real and not an
episode of punk'd
um it was so so pretty i mean obviously
pretty instantly
but still there's always that moment
when we like we're looking at the offer
where we're just like
like there's no way like like what like
first off out of nowhere second
like like i'm sorry ryan reynolds say
hi hi how are you you talk about
my man crush you know what i mean like
dude is an absolute
legend i love all of his films he plays
like basically the same character in
every single film and i don't care i
love it
it's never old it never gets old um so
and of course obviously everything that
sean's
pretty much touched and been directed
and directed has been phenomenal
so it was a no-brainer and also like
mind-blowing so it was an instant
yes i mean honestly if my agent ever
came to me with a deal like that and it
was a prank i'd probably be a little
heartbroken
as soon as we vetted it and especially
when you read the script and you can
tell that they are
really trying to be authentic to gaming
to what games are really like and
they're including
actual live streamers from the space or
gaming creators
i was like this is an instant yes a must
do and just absolutely honored to be
given that opportunity
i love learning about the like what
people do for a living and things that
might surprise people
so for both of you guys what do you
think would surprise people to learn
about being a professional live streamer
professional gamer
things that maybe they might not realize
i think especially for
people like ninja and myself what they
might be surprised to know
is that we have like entire teams of
people behind us
that help us on a day-to-day whether
it's a manager an agent
um someone who helps you with social
media or youtube content
editors like it truly truly takes a
village to run
all the channels that we have um so
it is kind of far from a one-man or
one-woman show
at least at this point in our careers
and it's it's a little bit more than
just
sitting at your pc and gaming though
that is a very important part of it
yeah it's um i think it's stressful is
what a lot of people
might not know um the the constant need
to
when it comes to live streaming when you
two like youtube sometimes you you can
obviously do
and crank out a bunch of videos in a day
like an eight hour session and then you
can maybe play those and have those
edited for a week
but like the live the pressure of like
live streaming it's any content creator
but live streaming like you have to be
there for six hours if you want to
stream for eight hours like you have to
physically be there for eight hours not
like a copy of you not
not a pre-recorded and like that that
can take its toll
um if you don't take enough breaks but
uh
to go with what pokey said as well as
yeah that team behind
behind like a lot of the bigger
streamers as we continue to grow our
brands even more
uh it's not it's not just us it's it's
it's
insane the the teams that
that you like you have to put together
to branch out
in the appropriate way and do it well
and and and to not slack
in like a department anywhere else
whether it be like you know your social
media your
you know content and stuff like that
yeah i think a lot of people might think
that when you shut off
uh from playing it's like oh you're just
gonna go chill but there's meetings
there's all this other [ __ ] you gotta do
when you're not yeah
the behind the scenes every morning dude
i i look over at my wife and she's just
like
you know it's watched the season before
then i go to bed you know i get a text
message
call at nine next calls at 9 30 meeting
at 11
and and like i'm just
just like don't stay up too late like
streaming and gaming and it's like okay
uh i am curious for you guys um what's a
game that you wish
more people talked about yeah if it's
fair to say valorant
i love valerian i think it's such a
great game
i've been a big fan since literally day
one before day one since beta when we
got to try it
i remember me and ninja both got to try
it in beta and it was
really really really really fun um i do
think it's garnered so much attention
and popularity obviously but
i think it could be even bigger and i
hope it grows on twitch as well
yeah i i can kind of second that i think
that now i think that finally now it's
getting
a lot of traction in terms of the
competitive scene it's
like really taking off on the esport
level which is fantastic
um but if i had to choose a different
game
there were two games one of them what
was the game where you turned into a
chicken
pokeman when you the battle royale i
remember
that was like uh it came out around the
time of fortnite
i don't remember what it is i never got
to play it but yeah it was a little bit
there's a god which is maybe why it's
not here today
uh i think it actually still is anyways
it was this game it was great
there were tournaments in it early on it
people were streaming it the biggest
streamers were streaming it
there was money in the tournaments and
for some reason it just
didn't pull viewers that like other
battles it was weird
like it had everything so it was just a
game i thought that that game was great
but again i don't know the name so and
then there's another one too
where the uh it was like the the retro
skating one that's not skating with the
retro game
the retro br games you remember that one
picky as well where you like
it was like in the base in the 70s and
you were like running around collecting
like
trash like disc bands and walkmans and
i don't think i played that one sadly
that game had that game got uh cancelled
because like they only had
their funding got cut but was it real
royale
it was realm royale was the first game
yeah there we go
let's go anyways look there we go that's
my answer from around
got it on that note i have to stop i'm
just gonna say congrats on being part of
such a cool movie
wish you guys nothing but the best thank
you so much nice meeting you have a good
one